Diana of Themyscira isn't afraid to speak
truth to power... or, failing that, to just
kick power's ass.
WarnerMedia unveiled new footage from the
upcoming Wonder Woman 1984 at their HBO Max
presentation this week, and it features Gal
Gadot's Diana engaged in a brawl in an unlikely
place: inside the White House.
The promotion machine for the sequel to the
2017 smash hit Wonder Woman is finally starting
to kick into gear, and while it doesn't look
like the new footage is going to be released
online, we have a detailed breakdown thanks
to the folks at IGN.
The footage heavily features Chris Pine's
Steve Trevor, whom you may remember appeared
to be quite dead at the conclusion of the
first film.
It's unclear how he'll return, especially
considering the nearly four-decade time jump
between the two movies; Diana may be a virtually
ageless quasi-goddess, but when it comes to
Trevor, the filmmakers will have some pretty
heavy narrative lifting to do in explaining
his apparent resurrection and failure to age.
Perhaps they'll steal a page from the classic
'70s and '80s Wonder Woman television series
— when it jumped time periods from the '40s
to the '70s, the presence of Trevor, portrayed
by the same actor, was hand-waved with the
explanation that '70s Trevor was actually
the original guy's son... who looked identical
to his father, right down to the haircut.
Sure, why not?
At any rate, the new footage opens with a
shot of Trevor and Diana strolling along by
the Washington Monument, with Diana wearing
the type of flowy, white dress that one might
expect to see on Themyscira, but not necessarily
in Washington, D.C.
In voiceover, she says the line of dialogue,
"I can almost see it, like a beautiful dream,"
as she caresses Steve's face.
In the next scene, Trevor and Diana are seen
under attack from gun-wielding assailants
in the halls of the White House, which doesn't
sound like a beautiful dream at all.
Like we said, we don't actually have access
to this footage — but it may look a little
something like the last time a superhero took
on the White House in the second X-Men movie.
It might also look a little bit like this.
Just use your imagination.
In the actual footage, Diana is wearing that
crazy new armor that was teased in a promotional
one-sheet back in June, and she has her hands
full protecting Trevor from incoming gunfire
while taking down baddies.
The clip briefly moves to slow motion as Diana
snatches away an attacker's gun and deftly
unloads it, then she brings her lasso into
play, roping guys in and pulling them towards
her so she can deliver finishing blows in
a maneuver that would make Mortal Kombat's
Scorpion proud.
“Get over here!"
The clip ends as Diana uses her lasso to deflect
a bolt of energy from an unseen opponent.
The footage reveals that Diana will be facing
down some powerful enemies, both in terms
of political power and... well, freaky energy
bolts.
Unfortunately, it doesn't clue us in as to
the deal with Trevor, so we'll just go ahead
and guess that he somehow survived his plane
blowing up at a high altitude, then went on
to invent the most amazing anti-wrinkle cream
the world has ever seen.
So far, only a precious few people have gotten
to actually see this footage from the movie,
as no trailer for the sequel has yet been
released.
However, thanks to director Patty Jenkins
spilling the beans, we now know when that
will happen: on December 8, at the Comic-Con
Experience in São Paulo, Brazil.
The flick's panel will close out the event,
which will be live-streamed via its official
Twitter page.
Although it hasn't been officially confirmed,
it's assumed that the CCXP spot will drop
online shortly thereafter; fans have been
waiting a long time, and principal photography
on the film wrapped about a year ago, so we
can probably expect a pretty beefy first trailer.
"What are you?"
"You'll soon find out!"
Hopefully, a bit of the mystery surrounding
the plot of Wonder Woman 1984 will be cleared
up when that trailer drops next month.
The first film's director Patty Jenkins also
helmed this installment, working from a script
she co-wrote with Shang-Chi and the Legend
of the Ten Rings scribe Dave Callaham and
comics writer Geoff Johns.
In addition to Gal Gadot and Chris Pine, the
cast includes Connie Nielsen and Robin Wright,
reprising their roles as Hippolyta and Antiope,
respectively.
Joining Wonder Woman newcomers Pedro Pascal
as Maxwell Lord and Kristen Wiig as Barbara
Minerva — AKA Cheetah — are Gabriella
Wilde, Ravi Patel, and Natasha Rothwell.
The movie hits the big screen on June 5, 2020.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.